on the other side of that extreme place  that i call suffering call whatever you  want  there's a whole other world  that people have not even examined  but you have to go to that extreme place  to examine it we want to stay here in  this comfortable place once you're going  to push yourself to that extreme place  it's like a whole nother universe it's  almost like like you're an astronaut and  you've examined something like up in  outer space no it's always been there  but you have to be going through all the  muck and all the sh  to examine and realized why god through  all this crap there's a whole other  whole universe over here in my mind yeah  yeah from the universe